الوضع في سوريا مشاهدينا سوريا المجاوره
ليس على ما يرام ايضا حيث ارتفعت حاصله
القتلى وفق احدث توثيق للمرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان الى
2700 قتيل منظمه الخوذ البيضاء ذكرت من
جهتها ان حصيده قتل زلزال في شمال غرب
سوريا ترتفع لاكثر من
1280 يعلم نظام السوري افاد قبل قليل بان
هزه ارضيه خفيفه شعر بها سكان اللاذقيه
وطرطوس وحلب وحمص
العشرات ايضا من العائلات السوريه الى
المبيت في المدارس او المباني الخاليه بعد
انهيار منازلهم بسبب زلزال في ظل نقص حاد
في المواد الغذائيه وماده النفط التي
يستعملونها للتدفئه
حلب
يعني
[موسيقى]
في مرت اخوي توفت
وبنتها طالب الجامعه
ببانياس لمشفى
[موسيقى]
جينا الساعه ثمانيه الصبح كانوا الاليات
والشغيله والعمال عم تشتغل وتحت
هزي عنيفه جدا المسار فالناس كلها طلعت
[موسيقى]
هذا وتواصل فرق الانقاذ في كل من ادلب
وحلب الجهود لانقاذ العالقين تحت انقاض
منازلهم فتمكنت من انتشار رجل وثلاثه
اطفال